all right you internet people it's
february 8th 2022 i'm dave rubin it's
the rubin report direct message we are
live streaming on rumble that youtube
thing and on blaze tv do me a favor
share subscribe tap notification bells
if you can find them etc etc i think
today and i don't want to over promise
but i think today is going to be one of
our biggest and most important shows
that we've ever done okay we've never
done anything like what we're about to
do which is going to be a full-on expose
of what i think is the biggest story of
the day because it combines every piece
of everything politically and culturally
that i've been yammering on about for
years the things that you all care about
and it's just the the perfect
encapsulation of why so many things are
wrong so many things are confused
how perhaps we can pilfer some truth and
honesty out of any of this etc etc so of
course i'm talking about what's
happening right now with joe rogan and
cancel culture and corporations versus
people and media dishonesty and the
whole damn thing so that's what we're
doing for for the full at least half
hour today so it's one story we've
crafted i think a a pretty uh compelling
narrative on the whole thing we're gonna
start from the beginning get it all the
way
to what happened yesterday which is that
rumble
officially offered joe rogan a hundred
million dollars to move from spotify
over to rumble uh to be completely
uncensored put his entire catalog which
was censored the second he joined
spotify over a year ago put his entire
catalog on rumble uh yours truly had a
little something to do with that
decision actually i don't want to tease
too much because i'm going to tell you
the whole story of how it all went down
but it actually was was my idea and uh
i'll tell you a little bit more on that
in just a minute so we're going to talk
really from the beginning of how this
whole thing started but before i lay out
the case and i'm going to try to do this
as honestly as possible and i'm going to
try to take into account all different
perspectives and everything else i want
to play a quick clip
of joe himself on his show not too long
ago
you made a really good point you said
the thing is if you sense yourself just
one percent you say i'll just censor
myself one percent that's what they want
i'm going to make them happy and then
they're just going to keep moving it
they're just going to keep moving it
forward moving forward moving the goal
post and providing you with more money
and giving you more things but keep
moving in a certain direction and if you
keep giving into it
they're going to have a hold of you
okay so that's joe rogan himself and i
want to be clear in everything i'm about
to do this is not a criticism of joe
rogan as i said on the show the other
day you know and i've been saying for a
while it's like he's just one guy he's a
comedian who suddenly through having
conversations
became more powerful than news networks
okay and everyone for the most part i
can't say everyone but most of us i
think that do something like this for a
living
are just doing the best we can and it's
going to come with some mistakes you're
going to be learning on the fly et
cetera et cetera so you can sort of see
rogan learning on the fly right there
now interestingly the guy he's talking
to in that very clip is alex jones now
alex jones doesn't matter what you think
about alex jones or what you think he's
said or not said or if he's a bad dude
or a savior none of that matters
he himself was booted off all of the big
tech platforms i've said several times
on this show that one of my regrets
in the last say two years is that when
it immediately happened i didn't offer
enough of a defense i did say
immediately that i didn't think he
should be kicked off but i should have
been louder about it because it
obviously wasn't going to stop with alex
jones and again that has nothing to do
with anything that he said or didn't say
it's like there's plenty of awful people
on social media many of them work for
giant corporations and they're out there
spewing neo-racism and all sorts of
terrible stuff but what you can see
there is joe rogan making an honest
assessment of how this thing works but
if you give an inch they will just kind
of keep taking
and maybe they'll give you more money
and you'll be quiet again or whatever it
might be but it's just going to keep
moving on you well now that very
notion has come to joe's
doorstep
and joe if you remember about 10 days
ago this whole thing started this was
all about how joe through his
conversations with people like dr robert
malone uh who was one of the inventors
of the mrna vaccine the technology that
joe was spreading covered misinformation
and we had about three days in the
machine
the media machine where it was all about
joe rogan spreading misinformation and
he's getting people killed and they're
taking horse dewormer and other weird
things and he's a bad scary dude because
of that well that somehow didn't destroy
him so then the machine ramped up and
this compilation video of joe rogan
saying the n-word was
released and at no point i've watched it
several times was joe rogan using the
n-word to be racist he was often
repeating the word that someone else
said he was mocking those who say it
that sort of thing you guys all get that
but then joe i think made a mistake he's
just a man and he made a mistake and he
apologized for something that did not
deserve an apology here is part of his
instagram apology
hello friends
um
i'm making this video to talk about the
most
regretful and shameful thing that i've
ever had to talk about publicly
there's a video that's out that's a
compilation of me saying the n-word
it's a video that's made of clips taken
out of context of me of 12 years of
conversations on my podcast and it's all
smushed together and it looks horrible
even to me now i know that to most
people there is no context where a white
person is ever allowed to say that word
never mind publicly on a podcast and i
agree with that now
i haven't said it in years but for a
long time
when i would bring that word up like if
it would come up in conversation instead
instead of saying the n word i would
just say the word i thought as long as
it was in context people would
understand what i was doing but it's not
my word to use
i'm well aware of that now but
for years i used it
in that manner i never used it to be
racist because i'm not racist
but whenever
you're in a situation where you have to
say
i'm not racist
you [ __ ] up
and i clearly have [ __ ] up
but i do hope that this can be a
teachable moment
for anybody that doesn't realize
how offensive
that word can be coming out of a white
person's mouth
in context or out of
context my sincere and
humble apologies i wish there was more
that i could say but
all of this is just me talking from the
bottom of my heart it makes me sick
watching that video
all right
he gave an inch i would argue he gave
more than an inch there
now he's just a man i do not know what
pressure was brought to bear i don't
know what spotify said i don't know what
his agent said i don't know what his
wife said maybe his wife was just like
joe i've just had enough of this [ __ ]
and you just better apologize so we can
move on i don't like getting looks when
i go to whole foods i have no idea i
have none of us have any idea there's
one person who knows it's joe rogan but
he did give an inch there right he gave
more than an inch
this idea that you have to apologize for
saying things that you did not mean
right he did not call anyone the n-word
to be offensive
okay the idea that certain set of people
can't say a certain word i mean i'm sure
this is going to get me in some degree
of trouble this is really dangerous this
is really dangerous
should you be allowed to make gay jokes
if you're not gay
seth macfarlane and family guy would
have an awful lot to apologize for right
uh we see these people that make all of
these jokes they often do apologize but
never turn the money back right they
never return the money hank azaria for
25 years played apu on the simpsons
doing an indian and it was apu actually
was one of the best characters who i've
often said was probably the hardest
working guy in springfield totally
welcomed in the community he was a
friend of homer they did a whole episode
on immigration where homer is
anti-immigrant at the beginning becomes
pro-immigrant at the end the great song
about the kwik-e-mart you all know it
right it's like
you see what's happening here this is
really dangerous stuff but they got joe
rogan to give an inch they actually got
him to bend the knee
he does not i don't believe in my heart
that joe rogan really believes it's not
his word to say i have no desire to say
the n word i don't think in my entire
life i have ever said the n word to be
offensive have i ever said the n-word i
have
i've said it in a joking context
actually i'll tell you this right now
when i was doing stand-up in new york i
used to do a joke about the transformers
i'm talking about autobots and
decepticons and jazz was the one black
transformer and i did a joke about it
and i would say the n word
at the end not er i would say it ga gga
at the end as i was doing an impression
of jazz
talking about megatron and it would get
a huge laugh from white people black
people
asian people gay people and maybe trans
people i'm not sure
and one day i was on stage doing it it
was it would get a huge laugh like a
huge laugh
and one day i was on stage and the crowd
kind of well i heard a lot of groans and
i was just like you know what i'm just
going to set that one aside
now does that make me racist because i
said that
because of the color of my skin i should
not be allowed to say a certain word now
i get it there's no win in this for me
even by saying that right now now i'll
have a bunch of internet weirdos trying
to hunt down videos of that
um but the bending of the knee here i
cannot say certain things and then he
said something that was even more
dangerous
he said something to the effect of when
you're in a situation
saying i'm not i'm not a racist you
[ __ ] up
that is really bad because they level
accusations of racism at everyone
everyone they disagree with is a racist
look at all of the people who they have
dishonestly called racists over the last
five years forget about donald trump
they called half the country racist and
white supremacists for half for the last
five years so it's like actually if you
get called a racist and you don't defend
yourself if you're not you're the one
making the mistake it's not just because
they level an accusation that you
automatically have f'ed up of course
that's not true of course that's not
true so we really have to have a
conversation about this as a country
or whatever the hell we are at this
point we have to have a conversation
about this are we all going to apologize
just think
are we any more tolerant right now is
anything that's happening in this
country politically or culturally making
us more tolerant right now obviously
it's making us less tolerant if you if
joe rogan is completely silenced if
spotify gets rid of him if you delete
all of these episodes if you take all of
us out who dare to talk for a living and
try to think things through will we be
more tolerant at the end are we more
tolerant right now because uncle ben is
not on the rice box and aunt jemima is
not on the syrup container
we've removed black people from things
that everybody loved in the name of
equality or something like that
nobody's even sure why we did any of it
the land of lakes lady is gone did this
help are we less racist
this is all
complete nonsense at every level but the
nonsense continues and and why does it
continue it continues because all of us
don't really say what we think so then
we feed the monster we continue to feed
the monster so uh the spotify ceo daniel
elk released a statement now we've got
some of it here he said spotify team
there are no words i can say to adequate
adequately convey how deeply sorry i am
for the way the joe rogan experience
controversy continues to impact each of
you not only are some of joe rogan's
comments incredibly hurtful i want to
make clear that they do not represent
the values of this company i know this
situation leaves many of you feeling
drained frustrated and unheard i think
it's important that you're aware that
we've had conversations with joe and his
team about some of the content in his
show including his history of using some
racially insensitive language following
these discussions and his own
reflections he chose to remove a number
of episodes from spotify he also issued
his own apology
over the weekend okay so i think first
it's important to note
that when joe rogan signed the deal with
spotify i believe it was 46 episodes
were taken away immediately it was alex
jones uh it was joe's friend and
comedian brian callan a bunch of other
people they immediately did that so joe
this is just something that joe has to
like accept and come around to the
reality of it they said here's let's say
a hundred million dollars roughly at
least uh we're going to remove 46 of
your episodes so when he did that
he was signing a deal with the devil in
a certain way and again i'm not
begrudging it no one has offered me a
hundred million dollars and i don't know
if someone came to me right now a giant
corporation and said dave we'd like to
offer you a hundred million dollars you
do have to remove that one episode of
your show
whatever that one episode is you gotta
get rid of that one we'll offer you a
hundred million dollars like am i just
gonna just like that like just like that
like i'll say no to it's not even
life-changing money a hundred dollars
it's beyond imagination all the good you
could do for a gajillion people and
everyone you know and everything else so
like these are just easy things to be
like he's a sell out and uh
it's not that easy it's not that easy
but it's important to note in the
context of this story because this is a
story being told right in front of us
right now it's important to note that
when he signed the original deal he knew
that they were censorious he knew that
they did not like certain things to be
said also the way that the ceo spotify
ceo says that there it's like you
employees have been offended by his
racially insensitive remarks except he
did not say them to be pejorative he did
not say them to be offensive this is
everything about this a ceo treating
their employees like there are these
snowflakes you think this is a problem
you think this that five years ago when
a whole bunch of us were screaming about
what was happening on college campuses
do you think maybe it actually now
leaked out into reality it leaked out
into the real world and it's going to
destroy all of these companies and by
the way this will destroy spotify maybe
maybe that's the silver lining here
these places that they won't deserve to
exist ultimately i like the service of
spotify i actually still have spotify i
have some great playlists on spotify
maybe i'll share it with you guys i'll
share them in the reuben port uh locals
community actually i've got some great
spotify playlists i'm doing a yacht rock
yacht rock thing that you'd love right
now uh but
what he says there is we've offended
some of you because of this language joe
offended you and we're sorry about that
okay so you're sort of letting the
inmates run the asylum at that point
right you've you know like people work
at companies that they're not always
happy with everything that's going on at
the company it's very possible that one
of the three gentlemen in this room
right now is not happy with me is that
possible guys no no no not at this
company but at other companies it's
possible okay so then he says that joe
then decided to remove some of those
episodes so then it's like now we're
playing like a weird sort of semantic or
optics game right because it's like joe
chose to well they might have said joe
we're going to take away the 100 million
bucks so how can we make it make it look
like we didn't force you to do it so
could you just do it did joe in his
heart of heart
in his heart of hearts the guy that i
played that video a moment ago about you
don't give them an inch because they
give you money and they'll just keep
going do you think he honestly like like
in the most sort of forthright honest
way was like you know i really thought
about it
i said those words not to be offensive
i'm just one man i will i will do this
is what i want to do and i really have
offended people and this is my deep
shame
it's like nobody thinks joe rogan's a
racist
nobody does nobody thinks joe rogan has
killed anybody because of kovid we are
we are surrounded by we are encapsulated
by people that lie to us about
everything
but this has much more to do with the
media freaking out over a guy that's
replacing the media than it does
over
kovid or the n-word or anything else
i'll get to that in just a sec for just
a moment though i want to talk to you
about raycon
you know did you guys make a new year's
resolution this year if you did more
power to you but if not that doesn't
mean you shouldn't still find a way to
shake things up whether it's by
switching up your workout routine or
going someplace new whatever way you
challenge yourself this new year there's
no way better to do it than with a pair
of raycon wireless earbuds in your ears
raycon wireless earbuds are the best way
to bring audio with you because no
matter how much you shake things up
literally
no matter how much you shake you know
they won't fall out of your ears the
everyday earbuds look feel and sound
better than ever there's also awareness
mode for when you need to listen to your
surroundings so you can stay safe when
you're on the go with optimized gel tips
for the perfect in-ear fit these earbuds
are so comfortable and they will not
budge trust me
raycon offers eight hours of play time
and a 32 hour battery life you get
quality audio at half the price of other
premium audio brands it's no wonder
raycon's everyday earbuds have over
forty eight thousand five star reviews
right now reuben report listeners can
get fifteen percent off their recon
order at buy recon dot com slash ruben
that's by raycon dot com slash reuben
and say fifteen percent off on ray cons
by raycon.com ruben and now back to me
okay so what is this really about is
this really about
this comedian who has long-form
conversations with mma fighters and
comedians and politicians
a guy who is mostly a lefty who was a
bernie supporter i mean the funny part
of this is the people who love to cancel
people should still love rogan because
even though rogan has sat down with all
of these amazing thinkers on the right
and people who talk about freedom all
the time and has interviewed uh you know
say jordan peterson probably eight eight
or nine times it's like rogan still came
to the conclusion that he should vote
for bernie sanders and support bernie
sanders it's like that's a whole other
issue entirely but this is a guy who
left california because of taxes right
he gets 100 million bucks then leaves
california because of high taxes brought
to you by bernie types bought to you by
progressives to move to texas where
there is no state income tax so it's not
even like he has like a completely
holistic view of the world that fully
makes sense in line with whatever
they're trying to destroy it's just
also silly but perhaps it's not
about covid misinformation specifically
and perhaps it's not about
uh talking about the n-word in the past
even though you didn't mean to be racist
perhaps what this is about is that
it's an upending of the world order the
media landscape has changed so
drastically and this is the machine's
way of showing who's still
boss so here are two propagandists by
the name of brian stelter and jim acosta
these are democrats who are on a network
uh known as cnn which was a place for
news at one time although actually in
retrospect we didn't have the internet
so who knows how much they've been lying
about the entire time but these are
democrats who pretend to be journalists
um who now are quite happy actually that
spotify is punishing joe rogan take a
look
joe rogan is now apologizing after
videos resurfaced of him using the
n-word multiple times on his podcast
patriot takes which put the video
together as an organization that aims to
expose extremism on the far right the
video is an edited compilation of
different podcast episodes brian uh what
is joe rogan now saying
he is now apologizing and we're going to
find out if that's enough for spotify
the company has an exclusive
distribution deal with him jim this is
all coming to light because of the
recent controversy about anti-vaccine
rhetoric on rogan's podcast some artists
uh decided to quit the service one of
them india re pointed out this video
this compilation video and pointed out
that the language rogan has used around
race in the past is just as or maybe
even more problematic than his rhetoric
about vaccines that would be enough to
put anybody out of a job i mean to me
it's it seems untenable to have that
kind of video surface that kind of
compilation surface and keep one's job
joe rogan can continue to host his
podcast if people want to listen to it
they can but it doesn't have to be on
spotify there are many examples
including in hollywood and entertainment
where people have uh have lost their
roles for less than this and that may be
why spotify is being so quiet at the
same time i want to recognize there are
reasons why rogan has lots of fans
millions of fans people want to hear his
candid conversations but there's a
difference between that between candid
in-depth conversations and the kind of
vile that's in this compilation
i'll there is bile and it's being spewed
by you mr potato head the way they are
drooling
the way they are drooling at someone
should how could he keep a job what was
the line that would be enough for anyone
to lose their job that's basically what
acosta said notice that they never said
that he didn't use the n-word to be
racist he didn't use it in a pejorative
manner that he used it when he was
either repeating what other people said
or when he was mocking people or
anything else they never say that but
they do say far right there's a website
these people create compilation videos
to guard against the far right and then
they use the name joe rogan do you see
guys how this whole thing comes together
and why are they really upset one more
time guys why are they really upset do
you think that jim acosta democratic
activist jim acosta and democratic
activist potato head do you think that
they are actually offended by joe rogan
repeating a word
in a non-offensive way
or is it because more people are paying
attention to joe rogan that nobody
nobody would pay a dime for jim acosta
or brian stelter if they did not have
cnn next to their name and cnn which is
crumbling and jeff zucker just had to
step down and uh two been masturbated on
a zoom call and don lemon uh did some
weird [ __ ] and they had to get rid of
cuomo and the whole thing the place is
going down right the place is going down
okay fine
um but when it goes down jim acosta is
not going to be able to go independent
and create a podcast that anyone will
pay for
right
brian stelter nobody cares about brian
stelter these are people who are
corporate suck-ups
they are i don't know how to describe
them in any other way because they lie
about absolutely everything and they're
now lying about their opponent
because they want to take out their
opponent but it's even worse
than jim acosta and brian stelter
because now it's leaking into every bit
of our political machinery we've got a
quote here from the telegraph barack and
michelle obama are reportedly seeking to
move their podcasts away from spotify
adding to the company's woes as it
struggles with a misinformation
controversy and low growth one source
told business insider that the couple's
higher ground audio company's pitches
did not always align with spotify's
interest in popular wide-reaching shows
a few days later joni mitchell also
demanded that her music be removed
prince harry and his wife megan duchess
of sussex who have a deal to host and
produce spotify podcasts express their
own concerns over the spread of pandemic
related misinformation okay
barack obama
and michelle obama and we know that the
administration remember our surgeon
general
said about two weeks ago that perhaps
spotify should do something about
misinformation coming from joe rogan and
we know that jen sake
said a few months ago that the
administration flags posts for facebook
so that they can remove posts this is as
close as you can get to violating the
first amendment without actually
violating the letter of the law and
maybe it actually is doing that when you
apply that sort of public pressure by
the way facebook's
stock is absolutely tumbling right now i
think meta which is now the parent
company
lost something like 25
of their stock value and then in another
huge store yesterday and it's all
connected to all of this uh peter thiel
the original investor in facebook and
really one of the the few sane people to
come out of silicon valley mostly a
libertarian and i know him personally
and he's a good guy he just stepped down
from the facebook board so there are
major things happening major major
things happening but this is a moment
for good people to hold
hold their nerve right not not just fall
into the the pit the endless pit this
endless descent to hell that we're all
in and good people need to stand up i'm
trying to do the best i can i hope
you're doing the best you can but if you
want to see someone that won't do the
best they can here is former
presidential candidate and a guy who
i've interviewed
andrew yang he tweeted this yesterday i
don't think joe rogan is a racist the
man
interacts with and works with black
people literally all of the time
andrew yang deleted that tweet
so andrew yang got some people to be
mean to him and people anonymous people
on twitter must have said andrew yang
you're a mean guy and you defended amin
joe rogan joe rogan of course gave
andrea three hours on his show to you
know say whatever he wants and promote
himself and raise money and all that
good stuff but andrean deleted that
tweet
do you think for one second andrew yang
thinks that joe rogan is a racist
of course not of course not but the mob
comes and it's amorphous and it's and
it's mean
and i've seen it it's come for me
and it ain't fun
and years ago when it came for me the
first you know few months when it was
just unhinged lunacy because i was
announcing that i was leaving the left
in essence whereas i was not even that
it was when i was first saying hey
there's some problems on the left
and i would just get thousands and
thousands of tweets and i'd get i'd
literally get death threats to my house
and all kinds of other stuff that i
would prefer not to tell you you know
what happened to me lost a whole [ __ ]
ton of my hair developed alopecia which
it's all mine now we're back we're back
in business but it's not fun it's not
fun so i'm not diminishing that
but if we don't have people that will be
brave then we've got nothing so andrew
yang it's like you're done man
you're done you're completely done
uh then
it continued it continued with this guy
dwayne johnson better known as the rock
and here we've got some info from the
new york post
just days after publicly supporting joe
rogan dwayne the rock johnson
acknowledged the controversial
podcaster's repeated use of the n-word
calling the revelation a learning moment
so you need to understand this the rock
defended rogan first because the rock is
not an idiot
the rock is not an idiot
the rock is not an idiot he's not a he's
not a liar and a [ __ ] the rock knows
that joe rogan's not racist the rock
knows that
but then
this video goes around the mob starts
coming and even the rock
the rock you might say was caught
between a rock and a hard place and the
rock then retracted and basically the
implication is no no joe rogan is a
racist now
that would be fine
except
most rocks have skeletons in their
closet i think that's a saying and then
of course this tweet popped up somebody
dug this one up where the rock a couple
years back said to this random girl on
twitter at katyrobin23
shh
don't be angry miss katie it's not our
fault you're turning blank you can read
the word yourself i'm sure i'm
demonetized already but why add fuel to
the fire uh you're turning blank tricks
to put yourself through nursing school
shush
now that's to a random girl on twitter
it's a couple years back uh but why did
he say that t word that very offensive
two word is the rock a transphobe could
it be that we've all used words in ways
that either we regret or at the time
were okay or something like that but
you know what rock
you got to be destroyed now
by their rules not by my rules man
you you've shown that you are not nearly
as brave as you purport to be in a lot
of the movies that you're in
right what would the rock do i've never
seen any of the the fast and the furious
i've never seen any of them i think
that's actually one of my keys to life
i've actually never seen any of the fast
and the furious but i assume they're
doing things fast and they're pissed
about it and they probably don't
apologize for saying bad words would
that be a fair assessment of the movies
yeah they don't apologize in those
movies okay
so the rock the rock the guy the rock
is not the rock that you want him to be
okay but it continued it continued and
there are some people sort of making
some sense through this actually one of
the guys making some sense through this
is glenn greenwald now glenn greenwald
is a lefty he is an edward snowden lefty
glenn greenwald and i used to fight on
twitter all the time glenn greenwald has
repeatedly called me racist we've sort
of made amends privately once about a
year ago so we don't go at each other
anymore but i have obvious political
disagreements with him is what it is
that's fine but i like to give credit
where credit is due
and here he is on fox talking about this
issue that i'm mentioning about media
resentment
you know i think it's the same reason
why you look at why they're so obsessed
with fox news sort of the one place that
has always existed
in the large mediocre system that
deviates from what the rest of the media
is typically saying like why can't you
have just one place where people are
questioning your orthodoxies and it's
because the ability to control
information is an incredibly powerful
instrument that everyone who tries to
obtain it wants to safeguard and so what
you see with joe rogan is he's built an
enormous audience bigger than
essentially everybody on television an
audience that's young and ideologically
diverse and he does often question and
dissent from the pieties they're
attempting to implant in the minds of so
many people and as their ratings decline
and their audience evaporates they're
looking to censorship as one of the ways
to maintain this stranglehold on our
discourse there's a huge component of
kind of resentment on the part of this
insular class and liberal enclaves that
nobody else is entitled to have
influenced
yes glenn greenwald we're good to go man
uh by the way what's interesting
at another level about that is he's on
fox saying that okay now as he makes the
point they're always trying to destroy
fox right because fox is the only
counter place fox by the way is the only
network that will put me on and they put
me on completely uncensored i do things
live they've never once asked me to say
anything or not to say anything or
anything else when my first book came
out a couple years ago we tried to get
on every other network nobody put us on
it was a book defending liberalism but
actually they're anti-liberal that's a
whole other thing but what's interesting
about that is the guy that he's talking
to right there is a guy by the name of
howard kurtz and you might find it
interesting that howard kurtz used to be
a host on a network called cnn and you
know what show he used to host on cnn it
was a show called
reliable sources yes he was the host on
cnn of reliable sources before brian
stelter it was a sunday morning show and
i remember watching it growing up and i
thought it was really interesting
because i've always been interested in
media and he would do this honest
assessment of media and critique of
media and what are we doing wrong and
sort of let's look in the mirror and
figure out what's what i don't remember
exactly the controversy that got him
fired from cnn but then fox news picked
him up and there he is doing an honest
assessment of the media with a guy glenn
greenwald who is clearly not on the
right who is clearly not in agreement
with most of the stuff that is said on
fox news
okay but now it continues uh barry weiss
who of course was the new york times
uh
op-ed person
who
famously left the new york times two
years ago
she defended uh joe rogan and obviously
i've been somewhat critical of barry
i'll get to that in just a second uh but
she wrote ditto this is a tweet from
barry weiss uh this is a retweet of lex
friedman she wrote ditto grateful for
joe rogan and of course what lex said
was i stand with joe rogan it is not a
coincidence that the attacks calling him
racist come as pressure on spotify to
censor builds politicians and the media
profit on division and outrage they fuel
the extremes that make us believe we're
divided we're not we're in this together
so my only and i don't mean to be petty
about this but i do have to mention this
barry weiss thing because barry
as you know she wrote the original
intellectual dark web piece
in the new york times where she said
that if interviewers she was talking
about me and joe rogan specifically if
we talked to some of these scary people
and she was talking about mike cernovich
she was talking about alex jones and a
few others that we'd have to either be
cynical or stupid so she put that in the
new york times she called me and barry i
will talk directly to you and i've
texted you
so i'm not talking [ __ ] behind your back
you called me the next day
crying after the article came out
apologizing for putting it in there and
said that your editors forced you to put
it in there
so you were doing the same gatekeeping
that now you don't want done they're
forcing joe rogan to not talk to certain
people that's exactly what you did when
you were at the new york times i don't
mean to make this about you but why not
just admit that now you're free and
independent and on sub stack why not
just admit what you know to be true i'm
not making this up so that's that's just
a little sidebar and i apologize for
even bringing myself into this
at that level uh brett weinstein who of
course has been on my show many times
and who has survived uh cancelled
culture and
you know literally survived being at
evergreen state university when kids
showed up with baseball that's he had a
good tweet about this he said joe rogan
is taking flack because he's over the
target i support him for the very same
reason every other person who
understands the relationship between a
free exchange of ideas and liberty
supports him
thanks joe rogan so of course uh brett
is right there and it is good to see it
is rare these days but it is good to see
some of the people that have been
through the machine
uh not come out sucking up to the
machine and you know standing up for
what i know that they believe in so
props to brett on that one and now i
want to sort of link this to what
happened yesterday because yesterday uh
and the night before it actually started
the night before on monday night was was
a crazy crazy time so this whole story
is breaking all this spotify stuff and
the sensor stuff and he said the n-word
and all of the stuff that i've just laid
out here is breaking well
on monday
i had a big meeting in sarasota rumble
just opened up huge offices in sarasota
they were getting the uh most of the
team not the entire team we have people
all literally all over the world
programmers in eastern europe and spain
and all over the place but we were
getting the entire team people in canada
and the united states together as many
other people as we could for a first
company-wide meeting and as you guys
know locals the company that i started
to fight all of this stuff we merged
with rumble about six months ago and the
reason we did it was because they have
the distribution they have the the right
set of people involved to fight cancel
culture to stand up for the principles
that i'm always talking about here uh
you know it's like it doesn't take
village to build to raise a child but it
does take a village to fight big tech
and you can't do it on your own all the
time i didn't think i could just do it
on my own so we found the right allies
to merge with so we merge these
companies we're building some really
awesome stuff to stand up against
youtube to stand up against amazon aws
the whole thing and to defend free
speech so anyway there was a big
company-wide meeting there that had
nothing to do with the rogan thing
this had been planned for weeks
on monday and on sunday night the whole
you know people were arriving from all
over the world and we went out to this
big dinner
and we're all sitting at the table and
everyone's talking about joe rogan
because obviously this is not only the
thing that's happening right now but
it's certainly related to the work that
rumble's doing and what i do and
everything else
and i just said to everybody at the
table i was sitting across from chris
the the ceo the rumble ceo and i was
sitting across from assaf the ceo of uh
locals and a bunch of the other people
some of the lawyers and whatever else
and i said you know we need to just do
something nuts why don't why don't we
just make a hundred million dollar offer
to rogan publicly like can we do that
let's just do that and i was like sort
of kidding but also not kidding like i
don't actually know how much money
rumble has i was just like you know
let's just do let's just shock the
system that's what i kept saying the
system needs to be shocked we need to
show people that there's a chance and
that people will fight and something and
chris just freaking lit up a soft lit up
and it was everybody was like holy [ __ ]
that that's a freaking great idea like
that's what we should do that's what we
should do it chris immediately turns to
the lawyer can we do that and the lawyer
starts like kind of thinking and
mumbling a little bit
and then chris gets on the phone with
somebody they got to call an accountant
they call a bunch of people and then
chris comes back about 10 minutes later
we're going to do it we're going to do
it and we're sitting there and everybody
50 people everybody is going holy cow
this is freaking amazing like we're
actually gonna do something we're gonna
we're gonna give it our best shot right
like we're gonna offer rogue in the
off-ramp like if you don't like the
censorship of spotify i don't know
everything about his deal there
but if you don't like it and there's a
way to extricate yourself from that
situation hey you got a home here we'll
take all your stuff we will never censor
you do whatever the hell you want and
here's 100 freaking million dollars to
do it so the offer that we made was 100
authentic and then the next morning
uh chris the rumble ceo tweeted this out
and if i could just pat myself on the
back for a second i wrote it so there
you go i did have a little bit of help
but uh these are my words i think you'll
hear me in this dear joe
we stand with you your guests and your
legion of fans and desire for real
conversation
so we'd like to offer you a hundred
million reasons to make the world a
better place how about you bring your
shows to rumble both old and new with no
censorship for a hundred million bucks
over four years this is our chance to
save the world and yes this is totally
legit sincerely chris pavlovsky rumble
ceo i think you can hear my voice in
that thing i was the one i really pushed
they wanted to put dollars a hundred
million dollars instead of bucks i said
let's just do bucks make it friendly so
the offer is real i want to be very
clear about that i saw a bunch of people
the usual suspects and blue check haters
and all that stuff it's not a real offer
and they don't have the money and blah
blah blah it is a real offer joe rogan
or anyone associated with joe rogan if
you are watching this take a hundred
million dollars from rumble you will be
completely uncensored you can do
whatever you want to do and your entire
catalog can be up on rumble tomorrow
maybe today i'd have to talk to the
people but it is completely legit uh it
continued because in this weird culture
award that we're in every it never sort
of ends and everybody's got something to
say you may remember uh former president
donald trump the orange man with funny
hair uh he released you know he's been
booted
from big tech right he's not on twitter
or facebook or youtube or anywhere else
so he releases these press releases with
his logo on them here's what he said
about the whole situation joe rogan is
an interesting and popular guy but he's
got to stop apologizing to the fake news
and radical left maniacs and lunatics
how many ways can you say you're sorry
joe just go about what you do so well
and don't let them make you look weak
and frightened that's not you and it
never will be man
like yeah trump yeah
you're right and you know there's this
funny thing this idea of fu money right
i've talked about this before like
people are always like oh when you have
fu money
right like when you have so much money
that you can just say whatever you want
you will start saying whatever you want
and i know a lot of rich people and it
is very very rare that that's actually
what they do because you start feeling
like you have more things you have more
responsibilities you have more staff you
have more employees if anything you
become more quiet in that often i i
would say that peter thiel is is a
maybe the one and probably best reverse
example of that he's someone who still
is fighting for the things that he was
always fighting for and remarkably
consistent over 20 years if you watch
his videos from 20 years ago um but most
people once they get a certain amount of
money like and again i don't mean this
as a judgment to rogan
but it's like you got that money there's
a certain comfort a certain lifestyle
that comes with that and you have other
responsibilities so
this is messy it absolutely is messy by
the way there was one other guy who had
fu money who said fu to the whole system
yeah it was the guy that released that
press release wasn't it that was the guy
who had an awful lot to lose billions of
dollars his businesses are in shambles
right now like i can't imagine that the
trump properties are doing particularly
well right now
even the hotel in dc closed if i'm not
mistaken or they had to license out the
the name to someone else and that was a
freaking awesome awesome awesome hotel
um but he said fu and the system said
well here's what we can do to you
so what do we do with all this this is
frightening stuff this is this is
this ain't fun stuff
but i believe in humans i believe in
individuals i believe we can keep going
and keep fighting like it's what the
story of being human is it's what
biblical stories are about it's what the
grand narrative of the human experience
is
and by the way there are people that are
warning us about this
and have been warning us for quite some
time
so now i want to throw back to this guy
jordan peterson a guy who has been
through the machine and the machine
tried to destroy him
the new york times
tried to destroy him with a front page
article that he was for enforced
monogamy basically making it seem
like he wanted women to be subjected and
and
and othered by men and demand and just
at the whim of whatever their husband
wanted them to do of course it was
complete nonsense front page uh story in
the new york times uh written by nelly
bowles who is barry weiss's partner just
like another weird piece of the of the
puzzle here um and nellie actually is
quite red pilled i probably uh she
probably doesn't want me to say that but
i know that she is
it's just all pieces of this freaking
thing it just is
um well jordan peterson was on joe
rogan's show talking about how they keep
moving on you and it just keeps moving
and moving and moving i think some of
you will remember this clip i just don't
understand how it gets to the point
where things get to terrible places one
tiny step at a time you know if i
encroach i if i encroach on you and i'm
sophisticated about it i'm going to
encroach two millimeters i'm going to
encroach right to the point where you
stop start to protest then i'm going to
stop then i'm going to wait
then you're going to calm down then i'm
going to encroach again right to the
point where you protest then i'm going
to stop then i'm going to wait and i'm
just going to do that forever and before
you know it you're going to be back
three miles from where you started and
you'll have done it one step at a time
and then you'll go oh how'd i get here
and the answer was well
i pushed you a little farther than you
should have gone and you agreed and so
then i pushed you a little farther than
you should have gone again and you
agreed and if anybody's interested in
this sort of process and this is a
horrifying book if you want to read
about how this process works you can
read a book called ordinary men
i ordered ordinary men i have it on my
nightstand i have to dive into it i've
been a little busy for the last little
bit
but
do you think jordan peterson kind of
just explained the whole damn thing do
you think he just explained everything
about kovid do you think he just
explained everything about lockdowns and
masks and mandates
and encroachment on language and
destruction of people and cancel culture
and everything else and boy that sounds
an awful lot like what joe rogan said at
the top of the show we're going to show
you that one more time before
we head out today
but we have this knowledge guys and
while we can
exchange these ideas openly for as long
as we can and i get it youtube could
shut me off right now twitter could take
me out right now that's why i'm on
rumble actually that's why i started
locals like i'm good i'm good i'm
working with people that have the
infrastructure to stay alive it ain't a
perfect system
but any of us can be taken out at any
moment but if you think that your
silence is what's going to keep you
afloat
actually it's what's going to drown you
right your acquiescence is what gives
this thing air this thing needs energy
and you being afraid of it gives its
energy
go watch the never-ending story this is
the nothing it's here okay where's the
trey we could use a trejo and our tax
the horse who died in this pit of
sadness we could use that horse right
now who probably took ivermectiv
a couple comments from uh the locals
community and then i want to show you
that rogan video one more time uh jeff
says cnn is turning into a parody of
itself almost like how saturday night
live used to be funny yeah all of these
things they've they've all fallen on the
sword of wokism and as they've done that
they've rotted out any sense of truth
there and that's why it's very
it's very hard to relate to people that
watch these things it's why i'm very
proud that our show is on at 11 a.m
eastern now we are completely
opposed to the ideas that the lunatics
of the view are airing on abc right now
and if you watch this show
and your spouse or your friend watches
the view
let's say that's what you're doing at 11
o'clock
right if you're watching this right now
and maybe you're doing some work or some
other things whatever it might be but
you have a friend or spouse or whoever
that's just watching that
if that like that's a certain set of
information you're getting about roughly
the same things because the view is sort
of talking about the same things let's
say well you now are living in a
completely different world as them and
how do we arbitrage those two things i
don't know i don't know
that's why i moved to florida because i
i couldn't be around in california
anymore i said california five bucks
let's say we're at about 100 bucks right
now
vic says this is kind of how andrew yang
ran his presidential campaign too yeah
yeah unfortunately look i think yang is
a decent guy like i i enjoyed
interviewing him i'd like to play
basketball with him he likes old school
nintendo i don't think he has balls like
he just doesn't have balls and the
intestinal fortitude to stand up for
what he thinks is right i thought that a
lot of his ideas were sort of like
half baked but they were somewhat newish
and he was trying to be somewhat
moderate and so then that was like kind
of okay but like at the end like what do
we need do we need weak men right now or
do we need strong men i don't even think
i'm that strong like i i don't know what
the hell i'm doing i'm just doing the
best i can but but maybe that maybe we
just need more of that we don't need you
to be strong how about just do the best
you can and then we'll see what happens
caesar says you will always outlast the
critics if you stand your ground be
brave
that goes to every single person
watching this
and finally i thought we'd end with the
very same video that we started with so
that if joe or any of his friends or
co-workers or colleagues or anyone at
spotify is watching this maybe they will
hear those words
so before i throw to it then i'm going
to get out of here
i just want to say that that offer is
100 legit joe
you got an off-ramp man like how much
more could you want at the moment like
you can you can take the money and run
literally you can either take the money
and stay and be censored and have
warnings and have some of your catalog
gone and have to sort of
degrade your your past self
by staying there that guy was bad he
said bad things
i'm better now i'm more enlightened
or you could take the money the 100 mil
and maybe that's just a negotiating
start right huh i've said too much but
like we can do something here so you can
take the money and run and be free and
save the world why not
joe rogan ladies and gentlemen
you made a really good point you said
the thing is if you sense yourself just
one percent you say i'll just censor
myself one percent that's what they want
i'm going to make them happy and then
they're just going to keep moving it
they're just going to keep moving it
forward moving forward moving the
goalposts and providing you with more
money and giving you more things but
keep moving in a certain direction and
if you keep giving into it
they're going to have a hold of you and
they can control you